DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
HEARING.
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE'LL WAIT -- TO TO CALL THE
ROLL.
OUR FIRST STEP -- I BELIEVE IS
SENATOR SCANNER -- TO ASK HER TO
COME TO COMMITTEE SO WE COULD
HEAR HER BILL.
WELL HOLD WHILE WE WAIT FOR HER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CENTER SCANNER WELCOME.
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A QUORUM
SOUL.
BEGAN AS A COMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE AND I WELCOME YOU TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB.
ONE FORTY THREE THANK YOU SO
MUCH YES BE ONE FORTY THREE
BASICALLY RECOGNIZES THAT -- WE
FORTUNATELY STILL HAVE A ROBUST
MARKET FOR METALS RECYCLING BUT
AS A RESULT OF HAVING A ROBUST.
MARKET FOR METALS RECYCLING WE
CAN ALSO HAVE -- METAL THEFT SO
TO HELP REDUCE METAL THEFT.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW.
OUR TIME MIDDLE RECYCLERS TO BE
ABLE TO PAY.
THE PERSON WHO COMES IN WITH THE
SCRAP METAL.
WITH EITHER CASH [inaudible] FOR
WITH A QUIT GOING TO A DEBIT
CARD.
AND RIGHT NOW -- THAT'S NOT
ALLOWED WHICH IS WHY WE NEED TO
DO THIS BY STATUTORY ANNE'S
PREPAID CARDS CAN HELP PREVENT
METAL THEFT AND ALSO CHECK FRAUD
[inaudible]
I'M.
I'M GONNA STOP THERE I CAN GO
INTO MORE DETAIL MY CLOTHES
PHENOMENA ALLOW OUR MY WITNESSES
TO GO INTO DETAIL.
SO GET YOUR ONE STOP FOR ALL
RIGHT I GOT IT RIGHT HI THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN EMBERS RYAN
FLANAGAN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
WEST COAST CHAPTER.
OF THE INSTITUTE'S RAP RECYCLING
INDUSTRIES -- AND WERE SPONSOR
OF THE BILL.
WHERE TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED COMPANIES
NATIONWIDE HUNDRED OF WHICH IN
CALIFORNIA?
ITS MEMBERS ARE EXPERTS IN THE
HANDLING PROCESSING SHIPPING AND
RECYCLING OF RECYCLE SCRAP
COMMODITIES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN RECYCLING
COMPANY PURCHASES PURCHASES NON
FERROUS MATERIALS FROM A SELLER
THE COMPANY MUST A LATE PAYMENT
FOR THAT MATERIAL FOR THREE DAYS.
UNLESS THE COMPANY HAS AN
EXISTING BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE SELLERS SET FORTH MARK.
IN OTHER WORDS THE COMPANY MUST
BE FAMILIAR WITH THE SELLER THE
INTENT OF THE LAWS TO CURB METAL
THEFT.
THE THREE DAY PERIOD ALLOWS THE
COMPANY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENOUGH TIME TO DETERMINE IF THE
SALE LEGITIMATE AND IS NOT
INVOLVED STOLEN MATERIAL.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL MAKE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS TO
CURRENT LAW AS TO HOW PAYMENT
CAN BE MADE UNDER THE THREE DAY
SCENARIO.
CURRENTLY PAYMENT CAN ONLY BE
MADE BY CASH OR CHECK.
THIS BILL WOULD ADD ONE OTHER
PAYMENT OPTION WOULD BE THE
ISSUANCE OF A PREPAID BANK CARD
LIKE AN ATM CARD.
HOWEVER THE MONEY COULD NOT BE
DRAWN FROM THE CARD FOR THREE
DAY PERIOD IN ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH CURRENT LAW.
SOME OF THE VENICE BENEFITS OF
THIS BILL WOULD BE AS FOLLOWS --
WE FEEL MODERNIZES THE CURRENT
SYSTEM HELPS A NEW CONCERNS OF
CHECK FRAUD.
MANY OF OUR CUSTOMERS NOT BANK
ACCOUNTS AND THIS ALLOWS THEM
ACCESS TO THE MONEY WITHOUT
PAYING A LARGE CHECK CASHING
FEES.
ALLOWS THEM TO LEAVE THE
FACILITY WITHOUT LARGE
QUANTITIES OF CASH -- AND JUST
OVERALL THIS BILL IMPROVES
CURRENT LAW AND HELPS CURB METAL
THEFT FOR THESE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OUT THANKS.
GREAT THANK YOU RIGHT.
BEFORE YOUR SECOND WITNESS --
TESTIFIES CENTERS HERE LET ME
ESTABLISH A QUORUM OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT'S OKAY.
LATER HERE IS A HERE CHANGE YOUR
CHAIN HERE ARE TO LET UP YOUR
FERTILITY HERE DON GOD YANNI
HILL.
PHIL HERE LABOR THEY THEY HEAR
PAN WELL.
GREAT SO WE HAVE A QUORUM CENTER
SKINNER YOUR SECOND WOULD.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY CARROLLTON A WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AS YOU KNOW MANY OF OUR
LOW INCOME CLIENTS -- DO
COLLECTED METALS CANS THINGS
LIKE THAT TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR
INCOME -- IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
SOURCE OF INCOME ESPECIALLY I
THINK FOR SINGLE INDIVIDUALS.
PERSON TO MAYBE ON SSI ANOTHER
KIND OF PROGRAMS LIKE THAT.
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
TODAY I THINK IN PARTICULAR WHAT
WE LIKE ABOUT IT IS THAT THERE'S
NO FEES BEING ATTACHED TO THESE
DEBIT CARDS.
SO -- PEOPLE CAN ARE ABLE TO USE
THEM THEY CAN THEY DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE IS THE OTHER WITNESS
MENTION THEY DON'T HAVE TO PAY
CHECK CASHING FEES THEY GET THE
FULL BENEFIT OF THEIR LABOR.
AND ARE ABLE TO USE IT TO PAY
THE RENT AND TO BUY FOOD AND DO
ALL THE OTHER THINGS -- THE
REQUIRED BY THE NECESSITIES OF
LIFE SO WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
HERALD MISTER FLANAGAN ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
YOUR OTHER MEMBERS PAUL YOU'RE
ON BEHALF OF SCHNITZER STEEL --
WE USE THESE CARDS AND SOME
OTHER STATES 50% OF THE PEDDLERS
ACTUALLY PREFERRED THIS CARD --
SORE HELPING AN INDUSTRY WERE
HELPING INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE
THEIR LIVINGS OFF IT I WOULD --
DR -- TODAY THANK YOU GREAT ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT SEE NOW WILL BRING THE
ISSUE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CENTER LEVER.
I HAVE A QUESTION OF A COMMENT I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER -- ANY WAY
THAT WE CAN HELP FOLKS WHO ARE
DOING THIS WORK WILL ACCESS
THEIR MONEY AND NOT HAVE TO PAY
FEES.
I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
NOW WE DO KNOW THAT AS WAS
STATED SO MANY FOLKS -- THAT
COLLECT THESE METALS THESE CANS
AND WHATNOT ARE POSSIBLY
UNBANKED AND SO THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY HAVE A HARD TIME
CASHING A CHECK IF THEY HAVE A
DEBIT TYPE CARD JUST I JUST
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
VERY ELSE CENTER ARCHULETA YES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION --
IN AND I TO CONCEIVE -- THIS IS
A GREAT IDEA MY ONLY QUESTION IS
DOES IT TAKE THREE DAYS FOR THE
CARD TO BE ACTIVE.
BECAUSE BECAUSE I KNOW IF YOU
WRITE A CHECK OR WE CAN USE TO
CATCH IT MIGHT BUT IS IT IS IT
NECESSARY FOR THOSE THREE DAYS.
IT'S NECESSARY FOR THREE DAYS.
IT'S NECESSARY THAT IT TAKES
THREE DAYS BECAUSE OUR CURRENT
LAW.
DELAYS THE ABILITY FOR THE
SCHOOL THE BUYER OF THE SCRAP
METAL TO PAY THE SELLER. FOR
THREE DAYS SO WE CAN REDUCE
METAL THEFT S THAT'S ALREADY IN
STATUTE.
AND WHAT THIS DOES IS AVOID THE
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE LIKE IF
YOU'RE BEING PAID IN CASH THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE TO RETURN TO THE
FACILITY TO PICK UP.
YOUR CASH THAT YOU'RE OWED SO
THAT'S THE BET ANOTHER BENEFIT
OF THIS.
GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH VERY GOOD
CENTERS GUNNER I THINK THIS BILL
ALSO STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY IN THE
LIKE TO SAY IN CLOSING -- THE
ONLY THING I DAD AS I KNOW --
THE THERE WAS SOME CONCERN THAT
THIS MIGHT IMPOSE THIS MIGHT
TELL BANKS THAT THEY CAN'T --
PUT V. THIS DOES NOT REGULATE
OUR BANKS THIS IS PURELY THE THE
ISSUE AROUND FEES IS.
THAT THE METAL RECYCLER WOULD
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH SOME ENTITY
THAT PROVIDES THE DEBIT CARD IN
IN THEIR CONTRACT THERE WOULD
NOT BE A FEE ON THE USER OF THE
CART.
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
VISITING THE ELEMENT RECOGNIZE
CENTER LAID HIS MOTION -- TO
APPROVE THE BILL TO PASS.
TO AS A TO FLOOR TO PASS THE
FLOOR SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
LASER EYE.
LASER I CHING CHI CHING I
ARCHULETA.
ACTUALLY THE I. DODD GOD YANNI
HILL.
HILL I LEYVA.
LIVE I PAN WELL.
A BILL ENJOYS FIVE VOTES WERE
GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK.
OKAY NEXT UP SENATOR MCGUIRE SP.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE YEAH IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER [inaudible]
RIGHT.
WHY ARE WELCOME? EIGHT OF WE HAD
A NICE WEEKEND START YOUR DAY
OFF THAT THE ANTI WHAT A GREAT
WAY TO BEGIN THE WEEK TAKE TO
THE YES.
BETTER BELIEVE IT.
MISTER CHAIR IS THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I DID IT WAS IT WAS
PRETTY GOOD WEEKEND A LITTLE BIT
OF UP AND DOWN THE COAST BUT
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- IT TO YOU IN YOUR VERY
CAPABLE STAFF TEAM FOR OTHER
WORK AND SP.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE A BOTTOM LINE
THIS LEGISLATION IS A TRUTH IN
LABELING TRANSPARENCY BILL THAT
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR
COMPANIES USING NAMES AND
APPELLATIONS -- IN PRODUCTS IN
ADVERTISING IT ALSO FURTHER
CLARIFIES THE ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
CANNABIS IN CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
CURRENTLY IT IS ILLEGAL FOR
CANVAS PRODUCTS TO USE THE NAME
OF A CALIFORNIA COUNTY IN THE
PRODUCT'S LABELING MARKETING OR
PACKAGING.
IF THE CANNABIS WAS NOT GROWN IN
THAT COUNTY FORTUNE.
BUT THERE IS A LOOPHOLE UNDER MY
KERR SAID THE MATTER MEDICINAL
SIDE THAT ALLOWS FOR THE
LABELING OF CANNABIS PRODUCTS IN
MS MISREPRESENT THE NAME OF
APPELLATIONS.
WE RECENTLY SAW THIS FROM A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
MANUFACTURER WHO WAS
MANUFACTURING EMERALD TRIANGLE
CANNABIS THAT RAT WAS ACTUALLY
GROWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
IN IF THERE WAS AN APPELLATION
LAW IN WILL TRAIN GOAL IS UP --
ON THE NORTH COAST THIS CAN MAKE
CONSUMERS THINK WHAT THE PRODUCT
OF PURCHASING IS GROWN IN A
SPECIFIC REGION.
BUT CAN'T REALLY IT'S NOT -- IN
IT EXPANDS THE PROHIBITIONS RT
STATUTE ON IMPROPERLY USING
COUNTY NAMES FOR CANVAS PRODUCTS
TO INCLUDE ANY SIMILAR SOUNDING
NAMES AND APPELLATIONS IS LIKELY
TO MISREPRESENT THE ORIGIN OF
THE PRODUCT.
NOW WE MODEL THESE APPELLATION
OF LAWS.
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE ALREADY
HAVE WITH WINE ON AND THOSE LAWS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE FOR
MANY DECADES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IT IS
PROMOTED CORPORATE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN CLARITY FOR
CONSUMERS CANDIDLY WILL LIFT IN
WHAT WE HAVE WITH WINE NOW AND
PUTTING IT TOWARDS CANVAS VERY
SIMILAR CHALLENGES.
THE BILL ALSO ACCOMPLISHES THE
SAME THING FOR CANNABIS IT ALSO
CLOSES THE AMBIGUITY INSURERS
TRANSPARENCY FOR CUSTOMERS VIA
LABELING.
FINALLY MISTER CHAIR IT
CLARIFIES YOUR ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
CANNABIS IN MANUFACTURED
CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
IN EMPOWERS INDUSTRY TO CERTIFY
THEIR PRODUCTS AS ORGANIC UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ONCE THE
DEPARTMENT'S COMPLETE THEIR
REGULATIONS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THAT WAS
ALSO IN THE MEDICINAL SIDE WITH
THAT -- MISTER CHAIR -- I'M
GONNA TURN IT OVER TERROR CARVER
FROM THE HUMBLE COUNTY GROWERS
ASSOCIATION GENE HERS
REPRESENTING RURAL COUNTIES AS
WELL.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE A GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TO CORRECT HER CARVER
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE HUMBLE COUNTY GROWERS
ALLIANCE WE ARE A TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING WELL
OVER TWO HUNDRED LEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
WHILE THE WORD GROWER IS IN OUR
NAME WE REPRESENT THE ENTIRE
SUPPLY CHAIN INCLUDING MANY
MANUFACTURERS AND OTHER CANNABIS
RELATED BUSINESSES.
WE CHOSE TO USE THE WORD GROWER
INSTEAD OF CANNABIS BECAUSE WHEN
WE INCORPORATED WE WERE UNSURE
IF WE WOULD BE ABLE TO GET A
BANK ACCOUNT.
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE TRADE
ORGANIZATION WE DON'T TOUCH THE
CANNABIS PRODUCT IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM.
I BRING THIS UP TODAY TO
HIGHLIGHT THE REAL HURDLES THAT
THIS INDUSTRY FACES DUE TO
FEDERAL PROHIBITION.
AND HOW THESE OBSTACLES
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE CONSUMER.
DUE TO FEDERAL SCHEDULING.
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY DOES NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THE NATIONAL
ORGANIC PROGRAM.
ONLY THROUGH THE STATE PROGRAM
WILL WE BE ABLE TO CREATE
COMPATIBLE STANDARDS.
AND CERTIFY IN MARKET OR
CALIFORNIA GROWN PRODUCTS.
AS ORGANIC IN ADDITION TO THE
ORGANIC PROGRAM CALIFORNIA FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAS TAKEN
THE LEAD IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
APPELLATIONS OF ORIGIN PROGRAM.
FOR CANNABIS WHICH ALSO HAS A
STANDARDS BASED CERTIFIED
DESIGNATION.
WHILE APPELLATION OF ORIGIN HAVE
GLOBAL HISTORY THAT IS HUNDREDS
OF YEARS OLD CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ESTABLISHING THE FIRST SUCH
PROGRAM FOR CANNABIS IN THE
WORLD.
THIS PROGRAM IS AN ESSENTIAL
TOOL FOR THE REGIONAL MARKETING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF
LEAGUE LEGACY CANVAS PRODUCING
REGIONS IN CALIFORNIA SUCH AS
HUMBLE COUNTY.
THEY'RE STRENGTHENING THE
STANDARDS BASED MARKETING
PROGRAMS FOR LICENSE PRODUCERS
IN CALIFORNIA AS BE ONE EIGHT
FIVE IS AN ESSENTIAL STEP IN
PROTECTING CONSUMERS.
PROTECTING AGAINST COUNTERFEIT
PRODUCTS IN THE MARKETPLACE IN
SECURING CALIFORNIA'S POSITION
AS A LEADER WITHIN THE EMERGING
GLOBAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
HUMBLE COUNTY AND INDEED ALL OF
CALIFORNIA IS WORLD RENOWNED FOR
CANNABIS FLOWER MANUFACTURED
PRODUCTS.
AND WE TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN OUR
CRAFTSMANSHIP OF OUR WORK.
IN THIS BILL WOULD HELP ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS ARE
PURCHASING AUTHENTIC CERTIFY
PRODUCTS WITH ARAB VERIFIABLE
STANDARDS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY WE ASKS AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
PLEASE TO BE IN SUPPORT OF SB --
ONE EIGHTY FIVE RC RC HAS HAD A
LONG STANDING POLICY TO HELP
GUIDE POLICYMAKERS IN CRAFTING A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK.
OF FOR CANNABIS AND INCLUDED IN
THAT IS ON A PARTICULAR POLICY
ALLOWING FOR APPELLATIONS AS AN
ACQUIRED -- DESCRIBED ARE THERE
A HANDFUL OF RURAL COUNTIES WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF BERRIES ABILITY TO
MARKET IN BRAND THEIR LEGAL
CANNABIS PRODUCTS AND SO. FOR
THAT REASON WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GERMAN MEMBER LAWYER BEHALF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS YOUR MEMBERS TED
MALL HAS OUR BEHALF OF SECRETARY
OF STATE ALICE WITH DHEA
SECRETARIES IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OPEN TATIAN.
PROVISIONS THANK YOU.
HELLO KRISTEN UP AT ALL -- ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL CANNABIS
FARMERS ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.%
KAREN COMMITTEE JEANINE COLEMAN
FOUNDER THE MENACING OPERATIONSPROJECT.
AND EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE MEMBER
OF THE MINISTRY NO CANNABIS
ALLIANCE FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF
NORTEL CANNABIS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORTS.
PRICING THAT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
SOMEBODY FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HERE [inaudible]
EXACTLY.
THAT'S NOT ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR ACH ARCHULETA.
MISSED HERE I WOULD JUST LIKE --
TO COMPLIMENT YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION SENATOR -- THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY IS A BRANDING ITS
IDENTIFICATION I SEE IT AS
QUALITY CONTROL AND THAT'S THE
ISSUE RIGHT NOW WITH ALL THE
QUESTIONS ARE OUT THERE.
AND WE CAN WE CAN BRING THAT
INTO QUALITY CONTROL FROM COUNTY
TO COUNTY I THINK IT'S A GREAT
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THE GOOD SENATOR PAT.
pQUESTION ONE FAMILY SHOWS OF AN
AG COMMITTEE BUT SINCE I'M NOT
AG ANYMORE SO ACTUALLY THIS.
THE DOES THE PLANT CHANGE WHEN
AND DIFFERENT SOILS OR SO FORTH
THE CELL GROWING A CERTAIN
PLACES THAT ACTUALLY I MEAN
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT WHINING CLIMB
AND SO FORTH IS IT ACTUALLY.
IT DOES IT'S IT'S THE WAY OF THE
PLANT DOES GROW AS FAR AS WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE TREATING IT WITH
SO WHAT WE KNOW IS CONSUMER
DEMAND WHETHER IT'S FOR LETTUCE
TOMATOES CHERRIES OR CANNABIS.
IS GROWING FOR ORGANICS -- SO
CDFA WILL HAVE THEIR ORGANIC
STANDARD BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WE'RE
SEEING THE SAME THING IN REGARDS
TO THE WAY WE GROW THIS TERRIBLE
TO PARTY COMPARED EVERYTHING
ELSE BUT IN TERMS OF ALSO
LOCATION OF GROWTH I MEAN WHEN
YOU USE AN APPELLATION THERE SO
WHATEVER -- ABOLITION SO REALLY
WHAT THAT IS -- PROTECTING OUR
THOSE SMALL FAMILY FARMERS -- IN
LONG TERM AS WHAT'S AN ARCHER
LETTER WAS REFERRING TO IS THAT
THIS WILL SOON BECOME A
MARKETING TOOL IS WELL AND A
PROTECTION -- WITH IT FOR THOSE
FARMERS WHO ARE IN SPECIFIC
REGIONS SO WHAT WE KNOW AND FOR
EXAMPLE IN SENATOR DODD SISTER
CONSIDER GLACIERS DISTRICT THERE
ARE NUMEROUS APPELLATIONS ALONG
WITH CINEMA COUNTY AS WELL.
AND THAT THEN BECOMES A REAL
MARKETING TOOL -- FOR THOSE
GROWERS AND IT ALSO PROTECTS
FOLKS WHO WANT TO BE ABLE TO ADD
ON TO THOSE APPELLATIONS BUT
SIMPLY CANNOT BECAUSE THEIR
FRUIT ORDER CANNABIS IS NOT AS
GOOD OF COURSE TO GROWN IN THE
LIVERMORE VALLEY FOR EXAMPLE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU GOOD AT
THAT SO IT IS THERE A
APPELLATION FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY.
I SOON TO BE I'M SURE -- IT'S
GOOD I FRIENDS THE HALO OIL JUST
JUST DOESN'T HI DAN CAKE AND
THEN WE GOT HERE I DON'T KNOW HI
RIGHT.
SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENTS FROM
THE YOU HAVE SEEN -- FOR THEIR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE --
CENTER WHERE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR IT
DOES PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE WE JUST LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE IN THE CORNET WHO IS
OUR SENIOR FELLOW WHO'S BEEN.
WORKING ON THIS BILL -- IN HIS
BEHIND ME AND ALSO WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
MISS COLEMAN HE SPOKE HERE FROM
HIS YOU KNOW COUNTY -- IT'S VERY
CRITICAL AND SHE'S BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN THIS AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER WITH I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR ARE
YOU WORK SIR THANK YOU AS YOUR
SENATE FELLOW HERE BECAUSE HE
STAND UP.
OKAY THANK YOU WE LOVE OUR
SENATE FELLOWS.
ALL RIGHT -- DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
US SENATOR HILL IS MOVE THE BILL
AT THE SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
QUESTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE LASER HI
LATER I CHANGE.
TANG I ARCHULETA.
I ACTUALLY I DIED.
DOT IDEOLOGY ANI HILL.
HILL I LLEVA.
HAND.
RIGHT HAND I WILL.
I READ THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT CENTER MCGUIRE
GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NEXT TO THE CALL
OF THE THE SENATOR PORTENT TINO
SP.
THREE OH TWO GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR PLEASE PROCEED AS YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU -- SENATOR EQUATION
ACTUALLY IF I CAN HAVE THE
SERGEANTS BASS.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HONORED TO
PRESENT SP.
THREE OH TWO WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT -- COMMONLY REFERRED
TO AS GOLD IS TO CREATE A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TO ESTABLISH
AND OPERATE AN INTERNATIONAL
TRADE AND INVESTMENT OFFICE IN
YEREVAN IN THE REPUBLIC OF
ARMENIA -- THE ERROR OF ON TRADE
INVESTMENT OFFICE WOULD PROMOTE
THE EXPORT OF CALIFORNIA GOODS
AND SERVICES TO THE REPUBLIC OF%
ARMENIA.
AND FACILITATE ACCESS TO
EDUCATIONAL EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND ARMENIA --
IT WOULD FACILITATE PRODUCTS
BOTH IN BOTH DIRECTIONS WHICH IS
VERY EXCITING FOR THE ARMENIAN
COMMUNITY BOTH HERE AND IN THE
CAPITAL CITY OF YEREVAN.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO SB ELEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY THEN SENATOR JACK
GOT ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
ARMENIAN INTERNATIONAL TRADE
INVESTMENT OFFICE --
UNFORTUNATELY THE OFFICE WAS
CLOSED BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT DURING THE ECONOMIC.
DOWNTURN THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND ARMENIA
HAS CONTINUED TO STRENGTHEN IN
THE DECADES SINCE THE ORIGINAL
OFFICE CLOSED OUR MEDIA ITSELF
HAS SEEN STRONG ECONOMIC GROWTH
AS WELL.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
ARMENIAN ECONOMIC ECONOMY GREW
BY SEVEN POINT 5% AND THE GROWTH
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS
ESTIMATED TO BE FIVE POINT.
3% NOTABLY THE TECH SECTOR HAS
RAPIDLY EXPANDED IN RECENT YEARS --
DURING MY TIME IN THE SENATE I
WAS PROUD TO ESTABLISH THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CALIFORNIA ARMENIAN ART SOCK
MUTUAL TRADE ART AND CULTURAL
EXCHANGE.
THE COMMITTEE EXEMPLIFIES AN
INCREASED AWARENESS AND
COMMITMENT FOR ECONOMIC
COOPERATION BETWEEN ARMENIA AND
OUR WONDERFUL STATE THE RATE
REESTABLISHMENT OF THE
INVESTMENT.
AND TRADE OFFICE AND YET A MAN
IS A NATURAL EXTENSION OF THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE I PASSED
OUT A LETTER FROM THE MAYOR OF
GLENDALE -- IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSAL IS YOU KNOW GLENDALE IS
HOME TO A LARGE AND VIBRANT.
ARMENIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY AS
IS MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM MONTEBELLO'S DISTRICT AS
WELL AND TODAY I AM VERY VERY
PROUD AND HONORED TO INTRODUCE
THE CONSUL GENERAL OF ARMENIAN
LOS ANGELES.
DR ARMIN BY FOURTEEN WHO WAS
HERE TO SAY A FEW WORDS ON
BEHALF OF SP THREE OUT.
TO VERY GOOD CENTER THANK YOU
AND YOU HAVE AN ARMFUL GAS
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HONORABLE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
LET ME -- PRESENT YOU.
THE FOLLOWING FACTS THAT THIS
DIVIDE TOWARDS.
THE NEED TO ACTIVATE THE
RELATIONS SEINING
INSTITUTIONALIZED WAY BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND ARMENIA.
LAST YEAR.
IN APRIL MAY.
VELVET REVOLUTION TOOK PLACE IN
ARMENIA WHICH NOT ONLY CHANGE
THE POLITICAL LANDSCAPE OF THE
COUNTRY BUT ALSO THREE TWO CANAL
MAKE LANDSCAPE.
THE COUNTRY ADVANCED RAPIDLY
INDUCED PART SHORT TIME PERIOD
[inaudible]
AND THIS VELVET REVOLUTION LEADS
TO A GREATER DEGREE OF ECONOMIC
FREEDOM [inaudible] TO EASIER
ACCESS TO THE MARKETS. TO EQUAL
COMPETITION IMPROVED TAX
ADMINISTRATION.
THE GOVERNMENT STRONGLY
ENCOURAGES FOREIGN INVESTMENTS
AND AND CALIFORNIA IS A PRIME.
STATE. FOR ARMENIAN DISREGARD
BECAUSE IT FEEDS OFF ITS HUGE
ARMENIAN CMMUNITY AND OVER THE
EXISTING STRONG BONDS.
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND ARMENIA.
AND ALSO OUR MINION -- MODES
INNOVATION WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
FACTOR IN THIS PROCESS.
ALL THESE CHANGES THAT HAPPENED
IN OUR MEDIUM.
BROUGHT US TO A CONCLUSION THAT
THERE IS A HUGE ON TOP THE
POTENTIAL.
IN DEVELOPING CORRELATIONS
BETWEEN THE TRADE ECONOMIC
INVESTMENT RELATIONS BETWEEN
ARMENIA AND CALIFORNIA.
SO OVERRULED TRADE BETWEEN THE
UNITED STANDS STATES AND ARMENIA
ON ANNUAL BASIS.
BASED ON THE FIGURES OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IS ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR.
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS A PORTION OF
ONLY 17% IN THE STRAIT WHICH
ANOTHER.
TESTIMONY TO THE FACT THAT THERE
IS A HUGE UNTAPPED POTENTIAL
[inaudible]
SO.
ALSO WE CAN TALK ABOUT.
VERY STRONG POSSIBILITIES.
IN THE REALM OF IT AND HIGH TECH.
ARMENIA IS A THE THIRD COUNTRY.
ON THE TOP IN THE WORLD.
THAT HAS A 7% OF ITS GDP ONLY.
IN THE AREA -- FLIGHTY AND HIGH
TECH [inaudible]
ARMENIA.
HAS VERY STRONG RELATIONS WITH
SILICON VALLEY ARMENIAN
COMPANIES.
AND ALSO OUR MINION.
EVEN IT WOULD BE INTERESTING FOR
YOU TO KNOW THAT LA EX WAS
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME ON THE
SOFTWARE THE ENTIRE OPERATION OF
THE AIRPORT RON ON THE SOFTWARE
WHAT WOULD THAT WAS DEVELOPED.
IN ARMENIA THERE ARE AMERICAN
COMPANIES VERY MANUAL THEM.
ARMED OF BASED IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THEY BECAME INTERNATIONAL
COMPANIES LIKE SYNOPSIS THAT THE
EMPLOYEES ALMOST.
EIGHT HUNDRED A SPECIALIST IN IN
ARMENIA MICROSOFT IS PRESENT IN
ARMENIAN VERY MANY OTHER
COMPANIES.
AND I CAN.
TELL THAT.
THERE IS A HUGE.
EXCITEMENT AND GOOD WILL IN
DARMIAN COMMUNITY FOR
ESTABLISHMENT OVER THE
CALIFORNIA ARMENIA TRADE AND
INVESTMENT OFFICE AND I AM VERY
MUCH CONVINCED THAT.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS OFFICE
WILL CONTRIBUTE.
TO DEVELOPING STRONG KEY TRADE
ECONOMIC RELATIONS DEVELOPING.
SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA ARMENIA
RELATIONS AND IT'S MUTUAL -- OFF
MUTUAL BENEFIT THANK YOU GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I SING I WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SENATOR
ARCHULETA YES THANK YOU FOR
APPEARING -- WITH US TODAY AND
AS YOU MENTIONED IN MY DISTRICT
THE THIRTY SECONDS SENATE
DISTRICT.
WE HAVE A CITY OF MONTEBELLO
WHICH IS PROBABLY THE SECOND.
LARGEST CITY -- IN CALIFORNIA
WITH ARMENIAN POPULATION.
WE HAVE BEAUTIFUL CHURCHES WE
HAVE -- THE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY
IS IS THRIVING AND I'M SO PROUD
THAT SO MANY ARMENIANS HAVE
SERVED OUR COUNTRY IS VETERANS.
AND THE THE BUSINESSES THEY RUN
THE QUALITY -- OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE THERE.
EVERY SINGLE DAY PROVIDING
SERVICES TO NOT JUST MY DISTRICT
BUT ALL THE DISTRICTS.
AND I'M SO PLEASE IN ORDER TO
SEE THAT WE'RE TAKING THIS STEP
IN GOING FORWARD.
SO I SUPPORTED AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO ONE DAY VISIT.
AND AND I HOPE TO SEE THAT THIS
THRIVING AND WOULD BE AN EXAMPLE
FOR OTHERS THROUGHOUT THE THE
WORLD.
I THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ARCHULETA CENTER GOLD YACHT --
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
SENATOR PORTENT YOU KNOW WE WERE
SERVING TOGETHER THE IN IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN WE HAD THE
OFFICE'S PREVIOUSLY.
AND WE SAW THEM GO AWAY AND AT
THAT TIME I WAS WORKING FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARBER MATTHEWS
WE TRIED LEGISLATION TO TRY TO
KEEP A A SMALLER VERSION OF OF
TRADE AND COMMERCE AT THAT TIME.
AND EVEN THIS YEAR I WAS LOOKING
AT HOW TO BRING BACK SOMETHING
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU FOUND A
WAY TO GET THAT STARTED AND I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR IF I COULD.
THANK YOU SENATOR CALLS YANNI
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THAT SENATOR CHANG.
WORKING WITH.
ARE THE BILLS TO MOVE CENTER WE
LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE AND I'LL JUST ON ONE NOTE --
AGRICULTURAL IS ALSO A BIG PART
OF THE EXCHANGE -- RIGHT NOW AND
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH UC
DAVIS TO SEND SOME CATTLE
EXPERTS.
TO ARMENIA TO HELP WITH THEIR
THEIR BEEF INDUSTRY AS WELL SO
THERE'S LOTS OF POSITIVE THINGS
GOING ON AT THE MOMENT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
AND THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP SO THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
FOURTEEN OF THE MOTION BEEN MADE
TO PASS.
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AND
APPROPRIATIONS SUBCOMMITTEE BUT
AND SEE IF IT GETS OUT OF HERE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
LASER EYE LASER EYE CHANG.
CHANG I OR TO LET US.
HI ARCHULETA I DOT.
DOT I. KALYANI.
BECAUSE JENNY I HILL.
HILL I LIVER.
LIVER I PAN.
AND I WILL.
LOOKS LIKE THE BILL JUST HAS
ENOUGH TO GET OUT BUT THESE MAPS
NUMBERS SO WILL.
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY
YES I THINK I HAVE YOU HERE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING NEXT GO TO
SENATOR CHANG HAS TWO BILLS TO
PRESENT.
I CERTAINLY HOPE THERE'S SOME
COMFORT ANIMALS TO HELP US
THROUGH THE DELIBERATIONS ON
THIS MEASURE.
I DON'T SEE ANY IN THE ROOM BUT
CENTER CHANG WELCOME WHICH WILL
YOU GONNA PRESENT FIRST.
WHEN A PERSON IS THE? SIXTY FOUR
SIXTY FOUR OKAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TERROR
GLAZER AND AND WASTING
COLLEAGUE'S.
SB SIXTY FOUR REQUIRES THAT ALL
MUNICIPAL ANIMAL SHELTERS ARE
SPECIFIED MICROCHIP ANY DOG OR
CAT WITH CURRENT INFORMATION
THAT IS EITHER ADOPTED OR PLANE
BY A PET OWNER.
THIS WILL ULTIMATELY SAVE THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFUNDS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF EUTHANIZED AND SHELTER
DOGS AND CATS.
SB SIXTY FOUR IS NEARLY
IDENTICAL TO S. B. SEVEN OH TWO
OF TWENTY ELEVEN THAT PASSED
THROUGH WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND IT ALSO ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AS CO AUTHORS -- TODAY.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN HUMANE
SOCIETIES HERE APPROXIMATELY TEN
MILLION PETS ARE LOST IN THE
UNITED STATES MORE THAN SIX
MILLION ANIMALS WIND UP IN THE
NATION'S ANIMAL SHELTERS AND OUT
OF THOSE ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ARE EUTHANIZED.
AND IN CALIFORNIA ALONE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF SHELTER DOGS AND
YOU AND CASSIE EUTHANIZE EVERY
YEAR.
A SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF THE
PROBLEM IS IDENTIFIED ANIMAL
IDENTIFICATION AND THE ABILITY
TO REUNITE THESE ANIMALS WITH
THEIR FAMILIES.
ONLY 15% -- DOGS AND 2% A
CAPTAIN SHELTERS WITHOUT
IDENTIFY KEY IDENTIFICATION.
ARE REUNITED WITH THEIR OWNERS
AND BY CONTRAST.
ACCORDING TO THE JOURNAL OF THE
AMERICAN VETERAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATES VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALMOST THREE FOURTHS
OF LOST.
MICROCHIP.
CATS AND DOGS WERE LOCATED DUE
TO THE PRESENCE OF THE MICROCHIP.
MADE DOGS FOUND HUNDREDS OF
MILES FROM THEIR HOMES WERE YOU
REUNITED WITH THEIR FAMILIES TO
THE MICRO CHIPS AND OTHERS WERE
FOUND YEARS AFTER THEY WERE LOST
TO MICROCHIP TECHNOLOGY.
AND THERE IS A VARIETY OF
EXAMPLES ARE DURING THE COW FIRE
THE FIRE SPREAD SO FAST THAT
PEOPLE BARELY HAD TIME TO SAVE
THEMSELVES LITTLE LET ALONE
THEIR PETS AND AS A RESULT.
OVER THE FOLLOWING WEEKS FIRST
RESPONDERS CARRIED THOUSANDS OF
INJURED IN THIS PLACE AND ALSO
EMERGENCY VETERINARY.
HOSPITALS EMERGENCY ANIMAL
SHELTERS AND THE CHALLENGE WAS
THEN TO REUNITE.
THESE ANIMALS WITH THEIR OWNERS
AND IT WAS REPORTED THAT THE
LUCKY ANIMALS.
WHO HAD MICROCHIPS -- OF HAD
BEEN REUNITED BUT IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN DIFFICULT BECAUSE WHISKERS
WERE SINGED OFF YEARS PAINFULLY
BURNED AT THE EDGES FOR WILLIS
SHAVE FOR TREATMENT.
SO BASICALLY SOME OF THEM WERE
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
WITH THIS BILL WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF DOGS AND CATS THAT WIND UP IN
SHELTERS.
OF OR OR BE EUTHANIZED.
THE STATE OF RHODE ISLAND
CURRENTLY HAS A VERY SIMILAR
BILL GOING THROUGH THEIR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO REQUIRE
MICHAEL CHIPPING STATE WIDE.
AND WE WERE CLOS ACCOMPLISHING
THIS IN TWENTY ELEVEN BUT NOW WE
HAVE THE CHANCE TO SAVE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND DOGS AND CATS LIVES.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO MY WITNESSES HERE
NICOLAS SOCKET FROM SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION AND
TEN ALL TEAM FROM SAKS ARGUMENT
ASIDE FOR PERMANENT PREVENTION
OF CRUELTY TO ANIMALS -- YET
FIRST WITNESS.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICHOLAS
SACKETT DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION WERE PROUD.
TO SPONSOR SB A SIXTY FORMED
THINKCENTRE CHANG FOR IMPORTANT
LEADERSHIP ON THIS BILL.
SOCIAL COMPASSION LEGISLATION
WAS FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN WITH ONE OF THE COMPONENTS
OF OUR MISSION BEING TO REDUCE.
EUTHANASIA IN OUR SHELTERS.
AS IT IS ETHICALLY MORALLY AND
FINANCIALLY THE RIGHT THING TO
DO ALTHOUGH WE HAVE MADE STRIDES
WITH HER EFFORTS OVER THE YEARS
ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT MUST
BE IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE IS
MICROCHIP BEING.
HAVING A PATCHWORK OR LACK OF
ORDINANCES IS NOT EFFECTIVE.
AS ANIMALS ONCE ON LOOSE HAVENO
BOUNDARIES A DOG OR CAT COULD BE
PICKED UP IN ONE COMMUNITY AND
DROPPED OFF IN ANOTHER SHELTER.
ONE OF THE PRIMARY ISSUES WITH
ANIMALS COMING INTO SHELTERS AS
LACK OF IDENTIFICATION CALLERS
FALLOFF FOR THE ANIMAL DID NOT
HAVE ONE TO BEGIN WITH.
THIS IS WHY AMERICA CHIP IS THE
ONLY REAL SOLUTION FOR ANIMALS
TO FIND THEIR WAY BACK HOME.
I'M SURE MOST OF YOU HAVE SEEN
IN THE PRESS ARTICLES OVER THE
YEARS ABOUT ANIMALS RETURNING
HOME BECAUSE OF THE MAKE
MICROCHIP SCAN.
THIS IS THE ONLY STORY THEY GET
THEM THERE.
IN THE STATE THAT STILL
EUTHANIZE IS ROUGHLY HALF A
MILLION PETS PER YEAR FOR THE
LACK OF SPACE AND RESOURCES AND
SPENDS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
TAXPAYER MONEY ON THE ISSUE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
WE GET NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE I'M KENNEL
TINA IN THE C. E. O. THE
SACRAMENTO SPCA WE ARE THE
LARGEST INDIVIDUAL PROVIDER OF
HEALTH CARE FOR ANIMALS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT SAVES LIVES
WHILE REDUCING STRAINS ON OUR
SHELTERS MANY OF OUR PUBLIC
SHELTERS WHICH ARE ALREADY
OVERWHELMED WITH ANIMALS.
I REACHED OUT TO MY COLLEAGUES
BOTH AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL AND
AS A MEMBER OF CAL ANIMALS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. TO ASSESS THEIR
THEIR RESPONSES TO COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE DONE THIS DALLAS TEXAS.
TWO YEARS AGO PUT IN MANDATORY
MICROCHIP PIC.
THEY DID IT IN ADDITION TO
ELIMINATING ALL OF THEIR
LICENSING FEES SO IT WAS NOT AN
ISSUE OF MONEY IT WAS AN ISSUE
OF SAVING LIVES.
THEY HAVE FOUND THAT RETURN THE
OWNER IN THE FIELD WHICH IS
WHERE AN ANIMAL CONTROL OFFICER.
HAS PICKED UP IN OUR HOME AND
TAKE IT DIRECTLY TO THE HOME
INSTEAD OF SPENDING AN HOUR
TAKING IT DOWN TO THE SHELTER.
AND INTRIGUE INTO THE SYSTEM.
NOW COUNTS 440% OF THEIR CALLS
WHICH MEANS THAT THE REST OF THE
TIME THEY CAN FOCUS ON THE
ANIMALS WERE ACTUALLY IN NEED
WHO POSE A SAFETY HAZARD TO THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE ENDANGERING LIVES
OR OTHER ANIMALS IN THE
AGGRESSIVE WAY.
AND IT FREES THEM UP TO FOCUS ON
THE ITEMS AND NEED THE THE
ANIMAL WHO.
WHO GOT OUT THE FRONT DOOR THIS
MORE?
THIS MORNING IS NOT IN NEED OF
EXPENSIVE ANIMAL CARE SERVICES
AS OPPOSED TO THE ANIMAL WHO'S
THREATENING OR ATTACKING OTHER
ANIMALS OR PEOPLE.
SAN ANTONIO AND I'LL MENTION
THAT MOST MAJOR CITIES IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS NOW HAVE
MANDATORY MICROCHIP AND ALSO HAS
FOUND THAT THEIR LIVE RELEASE
RATE.
AFTER MANDATORY MICROCHIP PAYING
WENT FROM 77% OF ALL ANIMALS
MAKING OUT ALIVE 292% OF ALL
ANIMALS MAKING UP A LOT.
SO IT IS NOT AN UNDERSTATEMENT
TO SAY THIS SIMPLE ACT A FIVE
DOLLAR CHIP.
WILL NOT ONLY INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF ANIMALS IN CALIFORNIA
WHO MAKE IT OUT OF THE SHELTER
ALIVE.
IT WILL REDIRECT OUR ARE SCARCE
RESOURCES AND MUNICIPAL SHELTERS
TO THE ADULTS WHO ACTUALLY NEED
OUR HELP AND THE COMMUNITY WHO
NEEDS THE SERVICE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR PLEASE
STEP UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
AND IF I YOUR NAME [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD ANY OUT ANYBODY HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
MISTER CHAIR ND MEMBERS A BIT
OF A TWEENER -- MICHAEL PIMENTEL
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AND AWHILE FOR ASSOCIATION WE
HAVEN'T UNOPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL -- WITHIN --
REFLECTED -- WITHIN YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS -- WANT TO
SAY THAT WE APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF OF FOUR
WORKING TO ADDRESS US AND THE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED BY
SHELTERS.
AROUND COMPLYING WITH THIS
MANDATE -- WILL CONTINUE TO WORK --
WITH YOU ALL TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ULTIMATELY SERVICE -- ITS
PURPOSE OF REUNITING OWNERS WITH
THEIR PETS -- WE WANT EMPHASIZE
THAT UNLESS A DOCTORS ROUTINELY
UPDATE -- THEIR CHIPS -- ONCE
THEY TAKE A DOG OR CAT HOME CHIP
HAS NO DATA WERE NOT RELEVANT
DATA I WHICH MAKES THE MANDATE --
YOUR PROBLEMATIC.
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO UPDATE OUR
POSITION UNFORTUNATELY BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE HEARING BUT WE
ARE REVIEWING THE BILL.
AND CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ART SCENE NOW WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
CALM THEIR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
YES SOMEONE IF SOMEBODY COULD
SPEAK TO THAT -- LAST -- DOES
MONA POLICE INTO THE UPDATING OF
THE CHIP INFORMATION ON THAT'S A
BIT OF AN THIS MISNOMER IN IN MY
MIND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
ASSOCIATION THAT MR MET PIMENTEL
IS REPRESENTING TODAY.
ALL CHIPS CARRY NOT ONLY
INFORMATION THAT YOU PROVIDED
BUT ALSO THE INFORMATION THE
ORIGINATING ORGANIZATION. ONE
ANIMAL THAT LEAVES MY SHELTER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO IF IT'S
PICKED UP OR FOUND SOMEPLACE
ELSE AND THE OWNER DOES NOT
RESPOND THEY CALL ME.
AND THEN I CAN TAKE THE ANIMAL
BACK AND WORK TO MY CHANNELS TO
GET THE ON MY BACK WITH ITS
OWNER.
SO THE OTHER COUNTER PART OF
THAT IS THE MOST LIKELY AND MOST
RELEVANT INFORMATION ON THAT
SHIP IS YOUR PHONE.
AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I
LAST LEFT LIVED IN TEXAS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND MY PERSONAL
PHONE NUMBER IS STILL A TEXAS
NUMBER.
BECAUSE THAT'S MY PHONE NUMBER
IS THE PHONE NUMBER ON MY CHIP.
ON MY BOTH MY DOGS IT'LL BE THE
PHONE NUMBER THAT THAT CALL NOT
THE ADDRESS THAT THEY REACH OUT.
TO GOOD AS SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU AND I THINK CENTER
CHAIN FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD WELL CERTAINLY THE
DATABASE MAY NOT BE PERFECT AT
CERTAINLY BRIDE MUCH MORE
INFORMATION THAN.
HAVING NO INFORMATION AT ALL SO
I THINK -- HOPEFULLY THAT WILL
BREAK I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT THE
ANALYSIS INDICATES THAT -- BEING --
THAT ANIMAL BEING -- INTERACT
WITH THE CHIP IS -- SIMILAR --
TO TO RECEIVING A ADMINISTERING
A VACCINE THAT WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT -- AS VACCINES DON'T CAUSE
AUTISM.
OF THE LDP CHIP CAUSES AUTISM --
LEAVE IT TO THE VETERINARIAN TO
SEE WHETHER A CHILD CAN GET OUT
THAT IT WHETHER A A AT A PET CAN
GET AUTISM OR NOT.
BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL.
HI -- CENTER CHANG -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE -- YEAH I I WANTED
TO THINK OF THE THE COMMITTEE
THE ULTIMATELY THIS THIS BILL
DOES SAVE LIVES AND SAVES
SIGNIFICANT TAXPAYER DOLLARS SO
WITH THAT I GOT.
FOR NINE THANK YOU SENATOR CHANG
AND YOUR WITNESSES -- CHAIR ALSO
SUPPORTS THE BILL APPRECIATE YOU
BRING IT FORWARD THE COMPASSION
FOR OUR WONDERFUL FOUR LEGGED
FRIENDS.
WITH THAT I RECOGNIZE SENATOR
PANTS MOTION TO APPROVE TO MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD TO MOST MISSION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
LASER HI THESE ARE I CHANGE HI
CHENG I. ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA
I'D DOT.
DOT I. GAL DANNY GAJI ANNE I
HILL.
PHIL I LIVE.
LIVE I PANTS.
AND I WILL.
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO MOVE
FOR RUBLE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN TRAPS TO MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SENATOR THANK YOU HAVE A SECOND
BILL TO PRESENT SP.
TWO FORTY FIVE YES.
DO YOU HAVE WITNESSES COMING UP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN -- MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I WOULD PRESENT HUGH SP TWO
FORTY FIVE THIS BILL WOULD WAIVE
ADOPTION FEES AT LOCAL PUBLIC AB
ANIMAL SHELTE FOR MILITARY
VETERANS.
MANY OF WHOM SEEK EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL COMPANIONS TO THE
PUBLIC SHELTER SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY TWO MILLION
VETERANS SOME OF WHOM ARE COPING
WITH PTSD OR OTHER SERVICE
RELATED.
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS RECENT
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT VETERANS
WITH PTSD AND AN ANIMAL
COMPANION HAD LOWER DEPRESSION.
A BETTER ABILITY TO COPE WITH
THEIR SITUATION.
LOWER LEVELS OF SOCIAL ISOLATION
AND AN OVERALL GREATER
SATISFACTION WITH LIFE REDUCING
THE VARIOUS ADOPTING AN ANIMAL
FROM A LOCAL SHELTER FOR THE
PURPOSES OF EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT STEP.
IN HELPING OUR VETERANS HEAL
FROM THE WOUNDS WE CANNOT SEE.
IN FACT -- LORRAINE SEE ON WHO
WE SHOT TO MY OFFICE WANTING TO
SPEAK WITH ME BECAUSE OF THE
BILL SHE HAD GOTTEN WORD OF THE
BILL.
HE IS A US ARMY VETERAN WHO
SERVED SIX YEARS IN IRAQ.
AND AFTER RETURNING HOME SHE HAD
PTSD AND SHE SOUGHT THE COMFORT
AND COMPANIONSHIP OF AN
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL IN FACT
WAS SUGGESTED BY SISTER.
ACTUALLY THREE CONSIDERATE SHE
DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD HELP HER.
SHE TOLD ME MADE SUCH IT WAS
MADE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT WERE
ALLOWED HER TO GO BACK TO WORK
HE NOW WORKS FOR A HOMELESS.
PROGRAM AND SHE SAID SHE HAD TO
BORROW MONEY FROM A FAMILY
MEMBER TO PAY FOR HER.
A NEW PET SO SHE CAME TO MY
OFFICE TO THANK ME FOR A CARING
THIS BILL.
COLE YOU MENTIONED A LOT OF
VETERANS DON'T HAVE THAT OPTION
SO THIS BILL OPENS THE DOOR FOR
SO MANY OF OUR VETERANS SEEKING
COMPANIONSHIP.
AND EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THROUGH
PET ADOPTION WITH ME HERE TODAY
IS A DOUBLE WHEN.
WHO SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS AS AN INFANTRYMAN
FROM TWENTY ELEVEN TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND HIS EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL AND COMPANION
MISTER BUT [inaudible]
MR BUT AND ALSO HERE TODAY IS
ALEX WARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES.
AND DUE TO A LAST MINUTE
SCHEDULING ISSUE THE FOLLOWING
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS OR IN
SUPPORT BUT NOT PRESENT.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERAN SERVICE AGENCIES THE
AMERICAN GI FORUM AM.
DEPARTMENT A CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERAN'S SERVICES OFFICES
CALIFORNIA STATE COMPACT
COMMANDERS VETERANS CAN COUNSEL
AND VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
YOUR FIRST WITNESS -- MISTER BUT
BUT MAYBE MISTER BUZZ COMPANION
HI.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS JACOB
ELON -- LIKE SHE'S -- SAID I AM
THE NICEST MARINE CORPS VETERAN
TWENTY SIX YEARS OLD I GO TO SEX
THE RIGHT NOW I CERTAIN SECOND
BATTALION SEVENTH MARINES --
DOWN TWENTY NINE PALMS TO TWO
DEPLOYMENTS TO THE OVERSEAS ONE
AFGHANISTAN AND WON DURING AS TO
MAX HALF OF TWENTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN DURING THAT TIME.
I WAS THERE WHEN THE US MARINES
AT THE US EMBASSY IN SANAA YEMEN
THAT WAS EVACUATED -- OUT OF
THAT PLACE AND SO -- JUST TO
GIVE YOU A PERSPECTIVE ON TIME
FOR AWHILE I FELL GETTING OUT OF
THE SERVICE WAS -- MID FEBRUARY
WE THAT DESTROYED THE EMBASSY
EVACUATED OUT OF IT LOST ALL MY
PERSONAL.
BELONGINGS ON THE WAY OUT --
WITHIN TWO MONTHS I HAD TO RE --
OUTFITTED IN THE MIDDLE EAST GOT
SOME OF MY STUFF BACK YEAH I
CAME BACK TO UNITED STATES NOT
MY FAMILY NEVER SENT THAT WITHIN
TWO MONTHS OF THAT I WAS OUT OF
THE MILITARY AND TO STARTED LIKE
HERE WE GO IS FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING.
ON I ALMOST IMMEDIATELY WANTED
TO GO BACK AND SAYS THERE IS
REALLY SLEEP HOME I DIDN'T WANT
TO BE HERE I CAN REALLY FIGURE
OUTWHAT IT WAS BUT IT FELT LIKE
SOMETHING WAS MISSING FROM
MYSELF AND WANT TO BE AROUND AND
AND MISTERBUT ENDED UP COMING
ALONG.
UNEXPECTEDLY AND DIDN'T REALLY
PLAN ON KEEPING AROUND BUT I
ALWAYS TELL MY WIFE THAT WE WERE
GOING TO KEEP HIM BUT I JUST
LIKE TO GIVE YOU MORE MORE MORE
ATTACHED TO HIM.
AND I STARTED FINDING A SENSE OF
PURPOSE TO REALLY WANT TO KEEP
HIM AROUND -- GOING FOR A COUPLE
MORE YEARS -- ACT SORRY.
WE SAID THAT TWO YEARS AGO MY
GRANDFATHER WHICH WAS THE MAN
THAT REASONING IN MY LIFE PASSED
AWAY -- FROM COPD AND I HAD THE
IMMEDIATE KNEE JERK REACTION OF
I WANT TO LEAVE I WANT TO GET
OUT HERE I WANT TO GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND GOING BACK INTO THE
MILITARY I'M GOING TO PRIVATE
MILITARY CONTRACTING I HAD.
CONTACTS THIRTY TO GET THE MEDIA
TO IRAQ WITHIN A COUPLE MONTHS
AND JUST GO AHEAD AND I CAN
LOGICALLY EXPLAIN TO MY WIFE
THAT THIS IS WHAT'S BEST FOR US
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE --
TO FINANCIALLY SUPPORT OURSELVES
AND DO WHAT WE WANT TO DO WITH
THAT BUT WHAT THE ULTIMATE
DECISION ACTUALLY CAME DOWN TO
WAS BUD AND WANTING TO STAY
AROUND HERE FOR HIM BECAUSE I
KNOW I CAN EXPLAIN TO HAND I'M
GOING TO DO THIS BECAUSE I'M
JUST GOING TO BE.
GONE FOR A LITTLE BIT I'LL BE
BACK IT'S OKAY BUT IT JUST BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT HIM THE IDEA OF
A LEAF AND JUST KEPT ME GROUNDED
AT HOME AND TO DAY I AM.
AT SIX DAY I'LL BE GRADUATING
NEXT SPRING -- WITH A BACHELOR'S
IN HISTORY WE ACTUALLY BOUGHT MY
GRANDFATHER'S HOUSE AND
CURRENTLY RENOVATING INSIDE OF
ITSELF AND MY WIFE IS PREGNANT
AND DUE IN OCTOBER AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT ANY OF THIS WOULD
BE POSSIBLE FOR THE FOR BUT
BEING IN MY LIFE AND FOR MYSELF.
I WAS THAT I WOULD WANT A BIG
MACHO PIT BULL OR SOMETHING I'D
BE JAIN ARM IS THE YOUNG GUARD
DOG AND ACTUALLY HAVE A SMALLER
DOG FROM ME.
TOMMY LOVE AND IT'S ONLY IT'S
OKAY TO BE AFFECTIONATE.
AND YOU KNOW YOU DON'T ALWAYS
HAVE TO HAVE LANGUAGE TO SHOW IT
TO SOMEONE SO.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU JACOB FOR A GREAT
TESTIMONY VEGETATION SIGNED
GRADUATING.
SOON FOR EXACT STATE THAT'S
FANTASTIC.
THANK YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TORRES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES WERE
VERY HAPPY TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR SP.
TWO FORTY FIVE FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IS A
CONSORTIUM OF SEVEN NON PROFIT
VETERANS SERVICE PROVIDERS
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS.
I CAP THIS MISSION IS TO ADDRESS
AND PROMOTE THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING EDUCATION HOUSING
MEDICAL AND BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
NEEDS OF VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES -- AS YOU HEARD HAD
ADOPTING A PET CAN GREATLY HELP
VETERANS WITH POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER GET RELIEF FROM
THEIR SYMPTOMS.
A REVIEW OF THE SCIENTIFIC
LITERATURE REVEALS A FIRM AND
GROWING EVIDENCE BASE THAT PETS
ARE VERY EFFECTIVE INTERVENTIONS
FOR VETERANS WITH PTSD WITH MANY
STUDIES SHOWING THAT PETS CONFER
A RANGE OF BENEFITS ON
FUNCTIONING AND MENTAL HEALTH.
IN A RANDOMIZED CONTROLLED TRIAL
OF VETERANS SELECTED IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS HEALTH
SCIENCE CENTER STUDY IN SAN
ANTONIO.
THOSE WHO ADOPTED A DOG FROM A
LOCAL PET SHELTER HAD
SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER RELIEF
FROM DEPRESSION AND LONELINESS
THAN THOSE PUT ON A THREE MONTH
WAIT LIST WHO WERE THE CONTROL
POPULATION FROM THE STUDY.
THIS BILL IS LIMITED TO VETERANS
WITH DMV I ID DESIGNATIONS AND
GIVEN THE ISSUANCE OF ABOUT
SEVENTY THOUSAND OF THOSE TO
DATE -- WE FIELDS PRAGMATICALLY
CRAFTED TO REDUCE ANY
DISPROPORTIONATE FISCAL BURDEN --
AS MR -- IN IN MISTER BUT HAVE
EXPLAINED -- THE SUPPORT
PROVIDED THESE VETS IS
IMMEASURABLE AND CAN WORK TO
HELP MITIGATE THE DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES ASSOCIATED WITH
PTSD.
WE THINK THE STATS THE SENATOR
AND HER STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL STRONGLY
URGE AND I FELT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT YOU COULD
COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS MICHAEL FROM
TELL AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL WELFARE ASSOCIATION WE
DON'T HAPPEN OPPOSE POSITION ON
THIS BILL RATHER WERE RAISING
SOME CONCERNS.
WE THINK THAT THE GOAL THE BILLS
ULTIMATELY VERY LAUDABLE AND IT
REALLY DOES RECOGNIZE IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT.
ANIMALS PLAY IN THE LIVES OF
EVERYONE -- ONE OF THINGS WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THOUGH IS IF THE
POTENTIAL OF FINANCIAL IMPACT --
TO LOCAL SHELTERS -- AND SO WE
ARE -- COMING TO THE AUTHOR ON
TO THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE WORK
THROUGH -- FINANCING MECHANISM
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THE
SHELTERS ARE MADE WHOLE I IN A
MEETING THE OBJECTIVES OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING THE ISSUE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMON --
QUESTION CENTER LABOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF CENTER
CHANG THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD JACOB THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING MISTER BUT I
THINK PERSONALLY WE DON'T DO
ENOUGH FOR OUR SERVICE MEN AND
WOMEN SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
AND THE FACT THAT YOU CAN'T
EXPLAIN TO HIM WHY YOU'RE
LEAVING WE CAN JUSTIFY IT TO
OTHER HUMAN BEINGS RIGHT.
BUT THE FACT THAT HE'S IN YOUR
LIFE TO MAKE YOU A BETTER
HUSBAND AND CONGRATULATIONS ON
THE NEW CHILD HE'S GOING TO MAKE
YOU A BETTER FATHER -- TO AND I
AGREE WITH YOU WE ALWAYS HAD BIG
DOGS WHEN I WAS GROWING UP AND
ONCE YOU HAVE A LITTLE DOG
THEY'RE KIND OF FUN.
BECAUSE YOU CAN TAKE THEM
EVERYWHERE IT'S HARD TO GET
EIGHTY POUND DOG ON A PLANE NO
ONE REALLY LIKES THAT.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TO
TESTIFY I DO UNDERSTAND THERE'S
SOME MONETARY CONCERNS BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO FIGURE THAT OUT
BECAUSE THIS IS THE VERY LEAST
WE CAN DO FOR OUR VETERANS.
THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA GO SENATOR HILL AND
THEN WE'LL GO AROUND THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE TABLE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR
THE TESTIMONY AND
CONGRATULATIONS ALSO IN THE
GRADUATION IS WONDERFUL.
THE QUESTION THE LETTER OF
CONCERN AND I KNOW WHICH
MENTIONED THE NUMBER BUT IN THE
LETTER AND IN THE OPPOSITION.
THE CONCERN THAT WAS HIGHLIGHTED.
IT INDICATED TWO MILLION
VETERANS IN THE STATE I GUESS
THAT'S THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
VETERANS THAT ARE IN THE STATE
BUT YOU HAVE MENTIONED THERE'S
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SEVENTY
THOUSAND OR SO WHO ARE.
THAT HAS THE BETTER INCENTIVES
DESIGNATION ON THEIR DRIVER'S
LIFE I SEE OKAY AND THEN.
V.. TWO THAT REALLY REDUCES THE
THE COST AND THERE WAS ANOTHER
POLICY ISSUE THAT WAS OUTLINED
IN THE THIS IS THE ANALYSIS
TALKING ABOUT IS THEIR NEED FOR
OTHER ANIMALS OR WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT DOGS AND CATS AND IS THERE
AN INTEREST IN.
LIMITING IT.
TO DOGS AND CATS WE ARE -- WELL
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME LIKE A
RABBIT.
OUR ANIMALS THAT YOU KNOW
VETERANS MAY CHOOSE. TO ADOPT
BUT IT'S IT'S REALLY FOR THEM TO
DETERMINE WHICH EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT AND MORE.
AS FOR THEM UT WE'RE OPEN TO
REIGNING IT IN TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S NO [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MUCH [inaudible]
LARGER.
ANIMALS I MEAN IF THAT'S IF THAT
IF THE COMMITTEE SO CHOOSES.
THANK YOU SENATOR HEALTH CENTER
ARCHULETA AND THEN.
SENATOR PANDA YET WELCOME TO MY
FELLOW VETERANS WELCOME HOME
SIMPLIFY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
AND I JUST LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOU A 100% BEHIND YOU THE ONLY
QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS IN
REFERENCE TO THE CALIFORNIA --
ID CARD THAT SAID BETTER ON IT
LITTLE DIFFICULT TO GET IN FIVE
MADE FOR THE FOR THE COMMITTEE.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET YOUR DD TWO
FOURTEEN TAKE IT OVER THE VA --
THEY VERIFY IT THEN YOU TAKE IT
OVER TO THE TO THE WHERE WE GET
YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE WHATEVER
THAT DMB MIGHT BE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO WAIT FOR IT
SO MY MY QUESTION IS IS THERE
ANY WAY THAT YOU CAN AMEND THAT
TO ADD -- THE DD TWO FOURTEEN
AND OR ANY OTHER MILITARY --
SERVICE CART VFW AMERICAN LEGION --
ANYONE ABOUT SO IT'S NOT
RESTRICTED ONLY TO THAT
CALIFORNIA ID.
WE WOULD BE OPEN BUT THE REASON
WHY WE MENTIONED VETERANS ON THE
DMV OR DRIVERS LICENSES TO KIND
OF RAIN AND IN A LITTLE BIT BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD LOVE -- O AT
SOME POINT PROVIDE THIS FOR ALL
THE VETERANS AND YA IN AND IF IT
IF IT SHOULD CALIFORNIA VALID ID --
IDENTIFICATION -- AND OR DD TWO
FOURTEEN OR OTHER -- VETERANS
IDENTIFICATION CARD.
PERIOD AND THAT WOULD ENCOMPASS
SOME OF THE PEOPLE THAT -- JUST
FIND IT TOO DIFFICULT TO GO TO
DMB TOO DIFFICULT -- TO GO TO
THE VA AND SO ON BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE DD TWO FOURTEEN AND A
DD TWO FOURTEEN FOR THE
COMMITTEE IF YOUR DISCHARGE
RECORDS.
SHOW OF ALL OF US SEEM TO FIND
IT AT HOME A LOT EASIER AND OR
KAREN YOUR MEREKA LEGION CARD.
JUST TO WALK IN AND THAT'LL DO
IT AND I THINK -- THE WHOLE IDEA
HERE TO OPEN UP BECAUSE I KNOW
WE HAVE BETTER INTO IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN BUT WE'VE GOT KOREAN
WAR VETERANS OF VIETNAM VETERANS.
WHO WOULD ALSO WOULD LOVE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS THEY MAY NOT
HAVE THAT SO THIS WOULD JUST
OPEN IT UP AND I THINK WOULD BE
MORE VETERAN FRIENDLY -- IF I
CAN RECOMMEND THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA SENATOR PAT.
I THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL I'D
HAVE A TECHNICAL QUESTION IS
THIS GOING TO APPROPRIATIONS.
NO OKAY PATRONS GOING STRAIGHT.
OKAY BUT WILL EVENTUALLY GO TO
PRESENT THE FISCAL [inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT WELL I KNOW NOT SURE
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T OKAY IT IS --
ALL RIGHT GUYS THAT'S QUITE
ALRIGHT SO -- FIRST OF ALL --
THE FIRST ONE WOULD THINK WOULD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE --
AND AND AND AND CERTAINLY WE
WANT -- TO AS A STATE AND AS
SUPPORT ALL VETERANS -- I I
THINK YOU WHAT YOU'RE HEARING IN
THE DISCUSSION IS A BIT OF THE
TENSION HERE RIGHT SO.
ON ONE HAND YOU KNOW YOU --
YOU'VE LIMITED THE BILL TO THE
PEOPLE HAVE THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
BUT THAT ALSO LIMITING BECAUSE
THE CHALLENGES OF GETTING IT
DRIVER'S LICENSE IN FACT MANY OF
THE VETERANS YOU MAY WANT TO
HELP.
WE HAVE SOME CHALLENGES GETTING
DISPOSING DRIVER'S LICENSE THERE
MAY BE CERTAIN REASONS OR
WHATEVER.
AT THE FLIP SIDE I THINK WE HAVE
SOME TENSION ABOUT.
THE COST IT HAS TO THE SHELTERS --
AND AND I THINK TO BE ENTIRELY
FAIR I DON'T KNOW HOW THE STATE
MANDATE COMMISSION WOULD VIEW
THIS AS THIS BECAME LAW.
SINCE THESE ARE PUBLIC SHELTERS
BUT IN MANY WAYS WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT WORSE ARE REQUIRING SOMEONE
ELSE TO PROVIDE NO IT'S VERY.
IMPORTANT USEFUL SERVICE FOR
FREE ESSENTIALLY.
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW I I
THINK THERE'S SOME CHALLENGES
THERE IN THE SENSE THAT -- AS
MUCH YOU KNOW AND I AGREE WITH
ALL THE TESTIMONY ABOUT THE
BENEFITS AND AND CERTAINLY OUR
VETERANS HAVE -- HAVE PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE TO TO TO
PROTECT US SO WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO HELP THEM -- BUT IN
SOME SENSES IF WE AS A STATE ARE
GONNA SAY WELL WE'RE GOING TO
WAIVE THE ADOPTION FEES ETCETERA
THEN WE SHOULD BE BACK FILLING
IT SOMEWHERE BECAUSE THE
SHELTERS -- MANY OF THEM --
THEY'RE RUNNING ON FAIRLY SHOE
STRING BUDGETS THEY NEED THOSE
THOSE FUNDS TO HELP YOU KNOW
TAKE CARE OF THE ANIMALS THAT
THEY DO HAVE THEIR UNTIL THEY
CAN GET THEM ADOPTED AND SO
FORTH -- SO I I THINK THERE'S A
STILL A LOT OF OUTSTANDING
ISSUES TO WORK OUT -- THAT WE I
THINK WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW WE'RE GONNA BE SURE THIS IS
ADEQUATELY FUNDED IN A WAY -- TO
BE SURE THAT OUR STATE OR
SHELTERS OR ARE ARE FINANCIALLY
YOU KNOW.
NOT GONNA BE OVER BURDENED TO
THAT BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
SHELTERS CLOSING FOR THE ANIMALS
WE WANT TO GET THE ANIMALS TO
THE VETERANS WITH -- TOO WHO WHO
WHO DESIRE THEM WITH THE MINIMUM
AMOUNT OF I GUESS BURDEN RIGHT I
UNDERSTAND.
PLEASE INCLUDING ALL YOU KNOW IS
VERY.
RIGHT OKAY.
AND AND AND ALL YOU KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW AND AS MANY BETTORS
POSSIBLE I THINK IT'S THERE ARE
TO LEAD A MENTION -- SO -- SO IN
THAT SENSE I A DOT B. L. I'M
WILLING TO VOTE FOR THE BILL
TODAY BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT STILL
NEED TO BE WORKED OUT I KNOW
IT'S GOING TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE
BY OCCURS THAT YOU WE TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HAVE A CONVERSATION.
WITH THE SHELTER TO SO WE NEED
TO BE SURE TO SHELTERS ARE.
ADEQUATELY SUPPORTED TOO AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT WHILE THE INTENT
OF THE BILL CERTAINLY IS VERY
LAUDABLE AND I SUPPORT.
THAT WE DON'T HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT BASICALLY --
MAKE ACTUALLY THAT'S LESS
AVAILABLE HAVE HARMED THAT'S
BECAUSE NOW SHELTERS ARE HAVING
FINANCIAL DIFFICULTY AND ALSO BE
SURE THAT THIS.
IS AVAILABLE TO MORE VETERANS.
AS WELL WHO MADE HIS WHO MAY
BENEFIT FROM THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR PANTS SENATOR
DODD.
YEP FALLING ON DOCTOR PEONS --
JUST NOT AS MUCH COMMENTS.
WELL WHAT IT WHAT IS THE COST
HE AVERAGE COST OF LOOKING
THROUGH. FOR FOR THIS RIGHT NOW
OR WHAT IS WHAT DID YOU PAY FOR
MISTER BUT ACTUALLY FOR MR BUT
WE DIDN'T GET INFORMATION ALTER
MY MY WIFE HAD HIS MOM IN -- THE
REST OF THE LIBERAL STILL BARNES
AND SO YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE TO
LIVE THROUGH IT AND SO WE RAISE
THEM UNTIL WE'RE GOING.
TO BE ABLE TO GET.
A SONG OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BUT I GOT TO CATCH TEM IN THE
OFFICE OF BONDING WITH THEM
DURING THAT TIME.
BUT THE AVERAGE NUMBERS ABOUT
FIFTY BOXES OF HEARING HERE.
IF IT RANGES ACTUALLY REALLY
FIRST A FLAT FEE FOR ADOPTIONS
FOR VETERANS WHICH IS A HUNDRED
DOLLARS BUT BUT IT WON'T BE A
BACK FLOW FROM THE STATE BECAUSE
IT IS.
IT IS WITH THE LOCAL SHELTERS IN
LOCAL COUNTIES FOR EXAMPLE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY CURLY WAVES
ADOPTION FEES.
OF FOR ACTIVE MILITARY MILITARY
VETERANS AND I JUST DON'T SEE IT
AS A HUGE -- BURDEN ON SHELTERS
BECAUSE AGAIN ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO KIND OF RAIN IT IN AS
A TO MAKE THIS KIND OF LIKE A A
PILOT PROGRAM IS TO HAVE IT WITH
THE DRIVER'S LICENSE FIRST AND
SEE HOW.
HOW THAT'S GOING TO GO AND I
KNOW MAYBE THERE WOULD BE SOME
QUESTIONS LIKE WELL WHAT IF?
IT WOULD BE -- ARE USUALLY A
LARGE VETERAN OF POPULATION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT THE VET BECAUSE THE VETERAN
POPULATION IS DISTRIBUTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THERE'S NOT
IT'S NOT GONNA BE A STRAIN ON
ONE SPECIFIC AREA SO.
LET ME -- LET ME JUST SAY A
COUPLE THINGS CENTER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
JUDGE JACOB THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMPELLING TESTIMONY AND
PERSONAL STORY ALEX THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER PENTEL
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO SHARE.
APPOINTED SENSITIVITY TO US AS A
COMMITTEE.
I THINK THE BILL IS -- IT WAS
ONE I'LL SUPPORT TODAY BECAUSE
IT'S A IT'S A MODEST IN SCOPE IT
HAS A GREAT PURPOSE.
BUT AS WITH ANY MANY THINGS WE
DO HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE WE
TAKE STEPS IN THIS CASE MIGHT BE
SMALLER STEPPED IN.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE BUT IT'S A
STEP FORWARD.
AND I THINK ALL OF US WOULD LIKE
TO SERVE OUR VETERANS COMMUNITY
IN ANY WAY WE CAN.
HI WITHIN SOME YOU KNOW FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS BUT THE OTHER BEAUTY
OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS
THAT THOSE THAT HAVE FISCAL
IMPACT CAN BE ANALYZED MORE
CAREFULLY.
BY OUR FISCAL COMMITTEE AT WORK
POLICY COMMITTEE HERE TODAY.
AND I THINK THAT I'M SURE WE'LL
GET THAT KIND OF REVIEW THAT OUR
MEMBERS ARE OF SHOWING SOME
SENSITIVITY TO THE YEAR.
AND I THINK THAT -- YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THEM -- TO
MAKE THIS BILL BE AS GOOD AS IT
CAN WITH AN AFFORDABLE RANGES
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT.
AND YOUR AUTHORSHIP YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO SHEPHERD THROUGH IN THAT
WAY.
SO I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT WHEN I
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSING
AND MORE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
FOR THE COMMITTEE'S KIND WORDS
TODAY WE DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SOMETHING TO HELP OUR
VETERANS WHO PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE FOR A COUNTRY.
AND IT'S QUITE MINIMAL AND WE
HAVE THE CHANCE TO HELP FOR
HEROES FIND SOME RELIEF AND
PEACE OF MIND THROUGH
COMPANIONSHIP.
AND THEIR STORIES LIKE THIS ALL
ACROSS THE STATE THIS IS JUST
THE ONE LITTLE THING THAT WE CAN
DO FOR THEM.
SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR I'M
GONNA RECOGNIZE MOTION FROM
CENTER LABOR TO MOVE THE BILL
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS.
TO A SENATE VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE.
LASER EYE.
LASER EYE CHANG HI CHENG I.
ARCHULETA.
VIRTUALLY DIED DIED.
DIED I GAL JOHNNY GOT YOUNG I
HILL.
PHIL I LABOR.
LIVE I PAN HI AND I WILL.
RIGHT THAT IS EIGHT VOTES SO
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
THROUGH THE BUSINESS AT HAND.
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ABSENCE
CENTERS I KNOW WE'RE STILL
MISSING AREAS.
ALL RIGHT -- CENTER WELL SO
LET'S START AT THE TOP -- S. B..
SIXTY FOUR I SENATOR CHECK IF
YOU COULD CALL THE ROLL AGAIN.
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTES EIGHT ZERO WELL.
I WILL DIE ALL RIGHT THAT VOTERS
OUT NINE ZERO SP ONE FORTY THREE
BY SKINNER.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CURRENT VOTES FIVE ZERO
DODD.
DODD IDEOLOGY ANI.
AJANI I'VE HAND BY HAND I WILL.
WILL DIE ALL RIGHT THAT BILL IS
OUT -- NINE ZERO MOVE ON TO SP
ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY MCGUIRE.
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE CURRENT AT
SIX TWO ZERO KALYANI.
YEAH JOHNNY I'D LEYVA.
LIVE I WILL [inaudible]
OKAY. ZERO NINE R. THAT FILLS
OUT.
NINE ZERO THAT'S B. TWO FORTY
FIVE BY CHANG THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE REAL.
QUESTION IS DO YOU PASS THE
SENATE VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTES EIGHT
TWO ZERO WELCOME.
WILL DIE AT BILLS OUT NINETEEN
ZERO SP THREE OH TWO FORTINO
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BOATS EIGHT TWO ZERO WOKE.
UP BY THAT BILL IS AT NINE ZERO
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING A PART
OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY THANK YOU
TO THE STAFF IS DOES SUCH GREAT
WORK FROM BOTH SIDES FOR ALL
YOUR HELP ON THESE BILLS.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED